-Welcome to the show.
-I'm delighted to join you.
-I was gonna say it's been an
interesting week in Washington.
But I feel that has been true
for a long time.
-It is.
-Yeah.
We are on a real streak of
interesting weeks.
This week,
you had the president saying
that what was happening with
family separation
was the Democrats' fault.
Obviously, the specifics of
the family separation,
that was not true, it was
the Democrats' fault.
But now, he signed
this executive order,
which still allows for
indefinite detention
and does nothing to get these
children back to their families.
Is it now, with those problems
that have been created,
is this a problem
for the president?
Or is this a problem for you
and your colleagues in Congress?
-Well, first of all, it's not
unusual for this president
to blame others for problems
that he had
a big hand in creating.
-Yes.
-And, so, just to be clear, he
created a policy a month ago,
back in May,
his zero-tolerance policy.
And that policy resulted in what
we've just watched, aghast,
on our televisions and,
you know, in discussions.
It's been heartbreaking.
His executive order yesterday,
we're all waiting like,
"Oh, is he gonna reverse this?
Has he finally acknowledged that
this was immoral
and that he needs to do
something about it?"
And then we read the details.
And, of course, it doesn't
address the over 2,000 children
who are already separated from
their parents.
And it doesn't -- I mean,
it doesn't change the fact
that we would be jailing
children with their families,
which is still wrong.
And, you know, it's as though
the United States government
has just kidnapped
2,000 children
and there is no plan to reunite
them with their parents.
And it's amazing that we're
talking about the idea that
we would need to have
Congress pass a bill to make
the administration
do the right thing here.
But that may end up
being what we have to do.
-With children being used as
political pawns --
-Yes.
-Which is something that
attorney general Jeff Sessions
basically admitted this is for.
Chief of Staff John Kelly
admitted this was a deterrent,
that if you take children
away from their parents,
less people will come.
Isn't it something -- you know,
obviously, this is something
the administration is doing.
Are you surprised that
your Republican colleagues
aren't stepping forward faster
saying,
"Look, there's one thing
none of us should ever do,
no matter what our party is,
which is to use children
as pawns"?
-Right.
But they haven't stepped forward
when it's happened in the past,
so this isn't the first time.
Although this is probably,
you know, almost unspeakable
to watch children
being ripped away
from their mothers and fathers.
But whether it's for deterrent
effect, as they say,
or to get his wall.
-Mm-hmm.
-He did this with Dreamers.
-Right.
-And he did this with the child
health insurance program,
which was allowed to expire for
weeks and weeks and weeks.
We're talking about children
getting the care
that they need
and not being dropped off of it.
So this is not the first time.
And most of it has been
as leverage for his wall.